esta carretera es el nuevo gran objetivo
de las fuerzas rusas que buscan cortar
el acceso a la provincia de lugares en
el este del país
de lograr su objetivo ciudades como lis
y chang quedarán aisladas y muy cerca de
quedar bajo el control del gobierno de
moscú
el cruce de fuego y los bombardeos hacen
que huir sea una misión marcada por el
peligro
este es el caso de natascha alexander y
llena que esperan la llegada de buses
humanitarios para ser evacuados
la noche fue el límite
atacaron este lugar ayer nuestras casas
fueron destruidas perdimos todo
da mucho miedo
empezaron a bombardear no es tan duro
imagínense un proyectil volando por
encima de mi cabeza y explotar en frente
de mí es un milagro que logramos escapar
de ese lugar después de horas de espera
han entendido que los ataques impiden
que los vehículos lleguen a su rescate
antonina aprovecha que los ataques han
mermado y ha salido a dar un paseo
tenemos muchos problemas con el agua
potable vamos al pozo y la sacamos de
allí
cada uno tiene sus razones para quedarse
a pesar de los peligros como misiles
como este que ha quedado sin explotar
en esta área se libró una de las
batallas más duras por el dominio del
este del país la ciudad ha quedado
atrapada en el cruce del fuego de las
fuerzas rusas ucranianas que la
defienden desde los alrededores
la vida para las pocas personas que se
han quedado indecisión es un básicamente
un infierno hay bombardeos hay
artillería que cae en las calles están
completamente solas nos dicen que no hay
agua tampoco hay electricidad no hay
conexión a internet no hay líneas
telefónicas y ellos nos dicen que
solamente cuando bajan un poco los
ataques salen a la calle compran su
comida y vuelven a sus casas a los
refugios subterráneos
la situación económica también impide
que muchos tomen la decisión de
marcharse como ara que vende las
verduras y huevos que producen su jardín
horrible la situación es horrible
bombardean todos los días incluso lo
hicieron el 9 de mayo ferrand el futuro
de la ciudad y los habitantes que
permanecen depende a la lucha que se
libra en esta carretera donde hasta
bailar bandera ucraniana sigue ondeando